more than a hundred million capital one
credit card customers and applicants
across the US and Canada have been
affected by a massive data breach the
company said yesterday a seattle woman
is under arrest she's accused of
stealing personal information from
credit card applications CTM consumer
investigative correspondent Anna Werner
is here and a good morning good morning
Capital one says this breach was
discovered on July 19th
they say the system's vulnerability was
immediately fixed but not before the
hacker stole personal data on thousands
of customers that includes about a
hundred and forty thousand social
security numbers in the US as well as
eighty thousand linked bank account
numbers the company says the bulk of the
hacked data was from consumers and small
businesses who applied for credit cards
between 2005 and early 2019 the woman
the FBI says is responsible for the hack
page a Thompson a former software
engineer for Amazon she's been charged
with computer fraud and abuse after
authorities say she bragged about the
hack online now this news of course
comes a week after the credit monitoring
agency Equifax agreed to pay up to seven
hundred million dollars for a 2017 data
breach that exposed personal and
financial information of about 147
million Americans
Capital One says it believes it's
unlikely the information was used for
fraud but it says it'll continue to
investigate and offer Kree free credit
monitoring services to those affected so
Anna if you're a Capital One customer
how do you find out if you've been
compromised and what do you do to
protect yourself so Capital One says
it's going to be notifying individuals
who have been affected by this breach
but they say if you recently applied for
a credit card you should take advantage
of the free credit monitoring offered by
the company and check it annually they
also say that you should consider
placing a credit freeze on your account
if that happened that of course makes it
harder for someone to open a new account
in your name don't forget to file your
taxes early before a scammer can
that's sort of disturbing information
you know change your online passwords
don't use the same password for
everything we've heard a lot of these
tips over and over again but you know
this keeps happening aspects of it is
Capital One has this vulnerability they
get hacked if someone opens an account
in your name guess who's liable for that
money you are guess you have to follow
the police report get their their name
yeah it's pretty complicated to sort of
unravel that whole picture if you get
involved in a caught up in a fraud and
we've talked to victims who have told us
of the years they've spent fighting you
know to restore their good name because
somebody else was vulnerable because the
credit card company didn't protect the
information or got fooled so this woman
actually they say from March to July is
when she was evidently doing this Wow so
they're lucky she was bragging right
that's the only reason hmm Anna thank
you very much